dix huit mois environ en boîte en france
des hommes et des dames aussi bien
qu'ils ont sur les oreilles un casque
leur permettant d'écouter la musique
même dans les bruits de la circulation
ce sont des walkman talent et l'on dit
qu'un certain akio morita voulez écouter
de la musique lorsqu'il joue au golf
ça tombait plutôt bien puisqu'il y avait
dans son entreprise un petit service de
recherche et développement ah oui j'ai
oublié de vous dire qu'il s'était off
c'était juste un des co fondateurs de
sony et le 1er janvier 1979 sort au
japon le premier walkman workbook même
watts même walkman et plus rien ne sera
comme avant
non pour les connaisseurs le lecteur de
cassettes stéréophonie est devenu
l'indispensable signe d'appartenance à
une certaine caste image de marque ils
véhiculent et celle de l'action de la
jeunesse et du dynamisme à l'époque les
responsables marketing et financier de
sony ne crois pas aux produits
akio morita devra faire preuve de
conviction et un peu de fermeté
c'est qui le patron deux ans à peine
après sa sortie en france on compte déjà
1 million de personnes qui possèdent un
bon coup même si ça c'est pas un succès
pour la petite anecdote sony voulait que
son baladeur et des noms différents pour
chaque pays
mais à peine sorti au japon le monde
entier parlait déjà du walkman alors la
marque a décidé de garder ce nom pour
tout le monde tout le monde parce qu'en
fait le monde entier le jeu de mots le
monde tout le monde on avait pu le
budget pour l'auteur ah oui c'est vrai
pour la plupart d'entre vous vous ne
connaissez pas le monde d'avant à cette
époque lorsqu'une marque lancer un
produit ça sorte et pays par pays
c'était rare les sorties mondiales la
communication et les échanges n'était
pas aussi rapide qu'aujourd'hui au début
des années 80 pas d'internet en france
on compte que trois chaînes de télé ça
vite fait le tour et quelques magazines
papiers spécialisés
autant vous dire que pour chercher une
information ou un nouveau produit il
fallait un peu plus de temps que de
taper une recherche sur google par
exemple pour frimer auprès de vos amis
vous pouviez dire que vous aviez importé
cet appareil avant tout le monde mieux
que vous l'aviez acheté pendant vos
vacances
ce qui était bien c'est que les produits
arrivés genre six mois un an après leur
sortie à free mais à l'époque ça avait
une autre gueule à partir de 1979 le
paysage urbain va définitivement changer
désormais il faudra s'habituer à ces
gens coupés du monde car
que sur la tête le walkman dans le métro
parce que ça représente assez important
parce que tu vas tu vois là c'est triste
mais trop les gens
la musique
voici donc ça détend c'est vraiment très
important
c'est une façon de se couper du monde
nous
quoi c'est une façon j'ai coupé du monde
je crois et puis aussi
j'aime bien la musique soit bon j'écoute
ce que j'aime puisque j'ai cassé que
j'enregistre tu pleures tu ne te moque
pas c'est le look des années 80 pendant
deux décennies le walkman est l'objet
incontournable des années 80-90 le jeune
possède un baladeur attention danger
écoutez de la musique aussi fort que ça
au dessus de 90 décibels plus de deux
heures d'affilée par jour c'est mortel
pour les oreilles
au bout de cinq ou six ans on risque une
surdité importante et définitif et ouais
les effets secondaires liés au walkman
c'est la surdité et la sécurité au
volant on en parle oui parce qu'au début
le vide juridique oblige on pouvait
rouler avec un casque sur la tête un
casque sur la tête
jeu de mots est tout aussi dangereux les
baladeur cassette en voiture même si
aucune loi n'interdit lusage les
responsables de la sécurité routière
tire la sonnette d'alarmé c'est
l'extérieur qui nous avertit du danger
et se rendre sourd artificiellement est
incompatible avec la conduite sur route
c'est pas parce qu'on a un autre manne
qui nous empêche de voir les voitures ni
les piétons
non je comprends ça soit dangereux non
mais si une ambulance arrive et klaxons
vous n'entendez pas ah ben non ça c'est
moi je la vois quand même oui oh ça va
elle la voit la voiture ça va elle la
voix superbe en 1985 apparaît le dic
sman c'est le même principe mais en
version cd pas super pratique parce que
si tu bouges est un peu trop et khatami
- un peu trop brusque
ben le disque sauter autant dire que
faire un footing
et cadix man c'était pas très pratique
malgré cette petite concurrence
technique le baladeur cassette traverse
deux décennies sans encombre mais à la
fin des années 1990 il est abandonné en
faveur des nouvelles technologies
émergentes le minidisc de décès c'est
bon et ils n'ont pas marqué l'histoire
par contre lui il a fait mal au baladeur
cassette un très très mal dans les
années 2000 la cassette audio analogique
devient obsolète et en octobre 2010 sony
annonce la fin de la commercialisation
de son baladeur cassette
en trente ans la marque aura vendu 220
millions d'exemplaires dans le monde et
je vous parle que de ce niveau nous
écoutons tout une mode
oui mais une mode peut être pas sans
conséquences il ne s'agit pas d' éviter
aux autres le bruit que l'on peut faire
mais de s'éviter à soit le bruit et la
présence des autres
mais non
pour les psychiatres c'est une nouvelle
rupture plus grave que celle des
générations alors ce danseur ou walkman
fait-il un pas en arrière ou un pas en
avant
ce sont appartient dorénavant au passé
le minitel ctu la nuit dernière pour
tourner cette page de l'histoire
française des télécommunications
trois hommes pendant trente ans ils ont
assuré le bon fonctionnement du réseau
hier soir ils ont veillé à son
extinction alors que le compte à rebours
est lancé
quelques usagers sont encore connectés
85 personnes connectées 85 sur le réseau
minitel un quart d'heure avant la fin à
87,1 23h45
nous sommes le 30 juin 2012
et c'est la fin du minitel 30 ans de
bons et loyaux services
l'internet avant l'heure je vous propose
de voyager dans le temps et de retourner
au début des années 80 la télématique
vous savez et bien c'est le mariage
entre le téléphone la télévision et
l'ordinateur et un mariage finalement
très réussie puisque déjà et bien on
voit apparaître des enfants les nouveau
nés alors les voici
il va voir et il est déjà en service
devront présenter l'annuaire
électronique en quelque sorte de parti
premièrement vous voyez un écran de
télévision sur lequel s'affichent les
renseignements que l'on trouve
habituellement dans la mer et puis un
clavier pour l'interroger
une variante également de ce système
c'est le télé tel cette fois ci c'est
l'écran de votre téléviseur relié un
clavier spécial et sur l'écran du
téléviseur apparaîtront différents
segments comme par exemple si vous aimez
la bourse les cours de la bourse ou bien
les horreurs de chemin de fer ou bien
les programmes des spectacles 1982 dans
les chaumières on voit arriver deux
innovations majeures le téléphone à
touches
parce qu'avant pour téléphoner fallait
faire ça oui je sais c'était un peu long
heureusement il y avait que six chiffres
mais le top du top de ses france des
années 80 en avance sur son temps
c'est l'invention du minitel pour les
puristes médium interactif par
numérisation d'information téléphonique
c'est une véritable révolution imaginer
le monde des années 80 il n'y a pas
internet
le seul moyen pour communiquer assez le
téléphone filaire s'est occupée
et puis un jour des ptt vous offre
gracieusement un minitel c'est un petit
peu fort quand même la lumière là non ah
oui ptt orange france télécom à l'époque
ça n'existait pas encore ça s'appelait
les ptt poste télégraphe et téléphones a
avant tout été ensemble la poste les
téléphones tout c'était le temps est la
même tel celui que vous aurez chez vous
du moins dans un premier temps se
présente sous cette forme cubique très
sobre de 25 cm sur 35 environ
cette grosse boîte s'ouvre sur le devant
pour faire apparaître un clavier tout
cet ensemble vous plaît avec le
téléphone permet d'interroger une banque
de données riche de tous les numéros
d'ille et vilaine
ça c'est pour l'immédiat mais dans
l'avenir il vous sera possible de
disposer de l'ensemble du gotha français
il parle de l'ille-et-vilaine parce que
c'était les premiers à disposer de cette
technologie révolutionnaire grâce au
minitel fini les annuaires ah oui c'est
vrai je suis là pour vous resituer le
contexte
à cette époque pour connaître le numéro
de téléphone de quelqu'un ou d'une
entreprise
il fallait un gros bouquin appelé à
nevers dans lequel il y avait tous les
numéros de téléphone j'en avais un blanc
pour les particuliers et un jaune pour
les entreprises il y avait tellement de
gens et d'entreprises qu'on ne pouvait
pas mettre la france entière dedans ça
c'est simplement paris en 1982 de i à z
de a à h
c'en est un autre c'était trop gros trop
lourd on n'avait pas forcément envie
d'avoir une bibliothèque des annuaires
de france près de son téléphone et qu'il
faut renouveler tous les ans en plus
alors on a édité des annuaires qui ne
recensait des numéros que par
départements situés en vendée tu
trouvais que des vendéens cet été à
paris tu trouvais que des parisiens
si tu étais de l'ille-et-vilaine et bien
que ne trouvait que d'éliminer lien je
peux faire tous les départements comme
ça c'est hyper lourd
et les mecs ils ivresse à chaque année
tous les abonnés des ptt recevait deux
annuaires
bonjour l' indice carbone de l'annuaire
bref vous avez bien compris que c'était
pas très pratique
ces histoires d'annuaire bon ok il y
avait les renseignements le 12 mai
c'était payant oui ça va je sais on n'a
pas dépensé des millions juste pour
numériser des annuaires le minitel était
un projet lancé sous la présidence de
valéry giscard d'estaing président de
1974 à 1981 au revoir
m
en plus de montrer que la france était
un pays très innovant le but du jeu
c'était de vendre du minitel dans le
monde entier l'idée était de proposer à
tous un mix d'outils de communication
personnels de source d'information utile
de shopping à domicile et même de
services bancaires
mine de rien il ya 40 ans grâce au
minitel la france va découvrir quelque
chose qui sera développé beaucoup plus
tard internet
[Applaudissements]
nous avons essayé d'en faire un système
de communication c'est-à-dire que les
personnes ont la possibilité d'une part
de laisser des messages à d'autres
correspondants et également de dialoguer
entre elles à travers le système et ce
point un succès absolument considérable
puisque pratiquement la moitié des
personnes qui appellent le système sont
engagés dans des processus de
communication entre eux
et ouais c'est le début des forums des
tchats et des mails bref on découvre une
nouvelle manière de communiquer pendant
dix ans le minitel connaît un succès
grandissant
en 1993 on compte 6,5 millions de
minitel en circulation ont distribué
gratuitement les minitels jusqu'en 1987
c'est à tactile consulter l'annuaire
était gratuit enfin les trois premières
minutes mais ce qui rapportait beaucoup
d'argent c'était les différents services
proposés c'était génial on pouvait
consulter de chez soi les horaires sncf
le chiffre d'affaires d'une entreprise
les résultats du bac l'argus de votre
voiture la situation de son compte
bancaire et les petites annonces pour
accéder à un service
il suffisait de faire le 36 15 ça
connecter le minitel et ensuite ont tapé
le nom du service
on a connu jusqu'à 25000 36 15 et sans
doute le plus connu le 36 15 lula c'est
ce qu'on appelait à l'époque le minitel
rose une sorte de 4 qu'aucun que des
mots pas de son et des images au dessin
très rudimentaire à l'époque il fallait
avoir de l'imagination et du temps et de
l'argent chaque minute était facturé il
ça pouvait me coûter cher très cher pour
une heure c'était 60 francs l'équivalent
aujourd'hui de 15 euros on a vu des
factures jusqu'à dix mille francs de
1450 euros
non mes calculs ne sont pas faux ils
correspondent à l'inflation de l'époque
voyez j'ai regardé sur internet pour
l'anecdote le patron de free xavier niel
a gagné ses premiers millions grâce au
minitel rose un nom jean n'a pas d'odeur
de 1994 à 1997 c'est l'apogée du minitel
mais on voit se pointer internet et les
connections illimitées sans frais
supplémentaires une résolution
écran bien meilleur des connexions
beaucoup plus rapide la fibre c'est dix
mille fois plus rapide progressivement
internet pousse le minitel vers la
sortie et le 30 juin 2012 marque la fin
du minitel
finalement cette formidable invention
n'aura vu le jour qu'en france on a
essayé d'en vendre à l'étranger ou la
fin d'une époque et un changement de
carrière pour les trois techniciens en
charge du réseau minitel demain ils
travailleront sur internet
non sans une certaine émotion ouais ça
fait un petit pincement au coeur
là on va dérouler les des opérations de
nettoyage maintenant pour s'occuper
l'esprit parce que beaucoup d'émotion
oui 36,15 connexion interrompue
définitivement
une autre information services mais elle
devrait plus tous nous concerner dans
les années qui viennent pour l'instant
il s'agit d'une expérience se pilote
avec l'inauguration aujourd'hui à
strasbourg du premier réseau français de
téléphone de poche ou téléphone baladeur
le be bop c'est son nom pèse 170 grammes
il était très judicieusement mis au
point par france télécom nous sommes au
début des années 1990 à cette époque le
téléphone portable c'est le radiocom
allô allô allô allô
je te reçois pas très très très bien un
téléphone portable gros comme une brique
et qui pesait le poids d'une brique et
ça vous coûter un bras
peut-être même deux je te reçois pas
très bien la moto c'était pratique tu
pouvais faire de la muscu avec non je
couche plus à cette époque pas de
smartphone pas de sms pas d'internet pas
de réseaux sociaux rien nada le néant
numérique pour téléphoner le seul moyen
c'était le téléphone filaire
alors fallait être chez soi j'ai des
amis dans un bar au boulot ou trouver
une cabine téléphonique
ils sortent de boîte dans lequel il y
avait un téléphone et ça sortait pas
toujours très bon tu insérer une pièce
ou une carte à puce est en fonction de
la distance de ton appel ça te coûte est
plus ou moins cher tu l'as acheté dans
un bureau de tabac
tu avais des unités dessus les crédits
et bien évidemment des crédits partait
plus ou moins vite en fonction de ton
appel de la distance il ya des gens qui
passaient leur temps à collectionner des
cartes à puce allons le forfait ça
existe pas encore quand vous attendiez
un appel fallait rester à côté du
téléphone chez soi au boulot dans un bar
chez des amis bref fallait près du
téléphone fallait attendre ça sonne pas
là non
voilà ça va sonner la non je crois que
je vais me regarder un film sur mon
magnétoscope vhs hi-fi stéréo pal secam
ntsc dolby surround ça a sonné la non
oui il y avait le répondeur mais c'était
un truc en plus et ça coûtait cher les
bieber ou les téléphones de bosch ont
envahi les trottoirs de strasbourg
téléphoner y compris à l'autre bout du
monde sur un bout de trottoir c'est
possible avec ses mini combinées de
poche
l'idée de france télécom c'était de
proposer un téléphone portable
financièrement accessible volonté en
fait d'en faire un produit de grande
diffusion
derrière be bop évoque bien le dynamisme
la vitalité le dialogue puisque le be
bop
je veux dire pour le danser il faut être
à dieu parce qu'en dehors devant être
installés et formeront un maillage
complet de l'agglomération permettant de
téléphoner de n'importe quel endroit
ce téléphone fonctionne il fallait être
à proximité d'une borne publique pour la
trouver il fallait chercher un
autocollant une sorte de jeu de piste
une fois trouvée vous deviez vous
déclarez à la borne je suis là non il
n'y avait pas encore les petites barres
pour vous dire si vous aviez dû raison
ou pas petit détail non négligeable il
ne fallait pas trop s'éloigner de la
zone d'à peine 200 m max on ne pouvait
pas se déplacer d'une bande à l'autre
non on pouvait pas pour recevoir un
appel
même démarche fallait trouver une borne
se connecter et attendre sans trop se
déplacer
ça y est je suis sur place non je bouge
pas tu peux m'appeler
non je préfère que tu m'appelles allez
faut raccrocher maintenant nantua
d'abord un de port-cros je suis un débat
il ya un an
je raccroche parce que sinon ça va me
coûter une blinde c'était le principe à
la même époque apparaît une technologie
concurrente est un petit peu plus
pratique le gsn en fait c'est les débuts
du téléphone portable que l'on connaît
aujourd'hui mais ça coûtait très cher
quatre fois plus cher et oui encore une
histoire d'argent
le be bop connu un certain succès
jusqu'en 1994
mais les prix côté gsm se sont
démocratisés et laventure s'est arrêté
en 1997
mais quand même on a compté jusqu'à
trois cent mille personnes qui
utilisaient ce téléphone cabine portable
bon il en espérait 500 mille ha
je crois que la mobilité eu raison du
hip hop véritable révolution dans le
mode de télécommunications ce téléphone
de poche accompli un vieux rêve un rêve
accessible
[Applaudissements]
18h30 sur les champs elysées plus de
2000 personnes ont un téléphone le
sacrifice 11h02 que nous sommes le 28
novembre 2007 ce jour la marque la
sortie en france du tout premier
téléphone apple
alors comment expliquer à celui qui ne
connaît pas l'iphone c'est d'abord un
téléphone mais pas n'importe lequel
il permet d'envoyer et de recevoir des
appels il permet d'envoyer et de
recevoir des sms
il permet d'envoyer et de recevoir des
mails il permet de surfer sur internet
en fait c'est un téléphone oui mais
quand tu l'as tu es quelqu'un qu'un
iphone
il est beau il est cher halo 3 heures
d'attentes pour être parmi les premiers
à l'arborer comme un trophée
399 euros + 49 euros par mois minimum
mais un téléphone pas comme les autres à
cette époque on est encore loin des
téléphones intelligents les smartphones
ok nokia ok ok ok nokia quelques marques
comme motorola samsung nokia ou
blackberry se partagent le marché
le blackberry les mecs ils avaient
réussi à mettre un clavier entier sur un
téléphone portable
c'était super ta pratique quand tu avais
des groupes où ce bref jusqu'à l'arrivée
de l'iphone les téléphones sont plus ou
moins innovante plus ou moins réussies
et plus ou moins beau mais lorsque le
téléphone de la marque à la pomme
débarque mais c'est une
vo lu tion mais un téléphone pas comme
les autres baladeur musical albums
photos que l'on feuillette défi grâce à
un écran tactile et l'accès à internet
illimité
même le pdg de france télécom s'amuse à
jouer les démonstrateurs c'est comme si
vous aviez une peau élastique vous tirer
dessus
ça grandit en plus d'avoir un objet trop
beau trop classe
le top et il faut bien l'avouer c'était
l'écran tactile alors oui ça existe des
gens mais là la villa mais là là ça
fonctionnait vraiment bien tellement
bien qu'on utilise tous des écrans
inspiré du premier iphone c'est aussi
l'apparition des applications en 2007
c'est la première fois qu'on voyait ça
il ya un petit icône tu mets ton doigt
dessus et l'application s ouvre qu'est
ce que c'est beau c'est chouette c'est
apple c'est la marque à la pomme
même si on était loin des résolutions
d'aujourd'hui l'écran était lui aussi
révolutionnaire pour l'époque ça avait
une définition de dengue 320 par 480 on
pouvait regarder son téléphone comme ça
ou comme ça au le téléphone ils
suivaient le mouvement s'était innovant
c'était magique
c'était beau et c'était tellement facile
à utiliser des points plus faible
apparemment
la qualité d'écouté orthez à l'oreille
autre point faible la vitesse du réseau
par contre il est wi fi ce qui fait
qu'on peut l'utiliser dans un réseau à
la maison
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à l'époque on avait beaucoup investi
dans l'innovation chez apple on s'en
fout un peu de lait coûte le truc le
plus surprenant c'est qu'il n'était même
pas 3g edge
ils étaient seulement en edge alors pour
charger une page internet il vous
fallait deux heures dans l'exagèrent
quoique bon vous pouviez utiliser le
wifi mais en 2007 ils n'étaient pas
aussi répandus aujourd'hui oui c'était
un petit peu la loose
il fallait juste se contenter de
quelques applications pas plus il n'y
avait pas encore de app store on pouvait
consulter la bourse
il avait déjà le google maps il y avait
la météo y avait la boîte mail il y
avait des contacts les sms les mms
il avait même pas un jeu il faudra
attendre 2008 pour télécharger les
premières applications
il y avait qu un seul appareil photo on
pouvait pas encore faire de celle fille
enfin si mais c'était plus compliqué
c'est peut-être pas la meilleure
invention sur le smartphone le mode
selphy ça n'a pas empêché d'en vendre
beaucoup mais beaucoup en 2009 deux ans
après la sortie de son premier modèle la
marque annonce avoir dépassé ses
objectifs de ventes 13,7 millions
d'iphone dans le monde qu'ils avaient
juste prévu d'en vendre que 10 millions
en juillet 2016 on passe le cap des 1
milliard aujourd'hui on a largement
dépassé le milliard 300 millions à vache
a quand même tendance à faire un beau
coup de téléphone
en fait c'est comme si tous les chinois
avaient un iphone au lieu de ça il est
fabriqué sans abonnement il vous en
coûtera 700 49 euros c'est cher mais la
marque à la pomme compte sur l'effet
crise qui caractérise le lancement de
chacun de ses nouveaux produits
[Musique]
aujourd'hui on connaît l'homme de
l'année
vingt deux il est à côté de moi je vous
le présente l'ordinateur individuel ou
pour l'appeler par son nom américain
mister computer pour un beau plateau de
lancement ça 1982 cette année symbolique
marque l'entrée dans nos chaumières de
l'ordinateur individuel ou ordinateurs
personnels pc du tout simplement avant
l'informatique était coûteuse et
inaccessible ce début des années 80 est
marqué par la démocratisation des prix
j'aime bien cette phrase parce que toi
moi le peuple nous allons pouvoir enfin
nous offrir un ordinateur un petit peu
fort là quand même là non bon on est
encore loin des machines d'aujourd'hui
il ya encore beaucoup d'enfants qui
jouent au pendu avec un crayon et une
feuille de papier mais il y a déjà des
enfants qui jouent au pendu avec un
ordinateur individuel
ouais je sais même à cette époque ça
devait être hyper en mieux comme jeu on
a un peu l'impression que la jeunesse du
début des années 80 vivait au ralenti
autant vous dire qu'à cette époque tout
le monde parlait de l'ordinateur tout le
monde voulait en avoir un et on nous
annonçait déjà qu'il allait
révolutionner le monde
on savait pas vraiment ce que cette
machine allait nous apporter mais ça a
l'air super ah ouais on avait quand même
de gros espoirs et pour nous éclairer
heureusement il y avait des gens
passionnés là je vous ai trouvé le tout
premier guide 1.0
maintenant que cet appareil est terminée
qu'il est construit je vais finir je
vais maintenant l'exploiter par la
première exploitation va être justement
une exploitation radioamateurs la
réception des signaux radio télé type la
réception des signaux un télégraphie sur
l'écran de la télévision et les missions
en radio télé type est un télégraphie
directement à partir du clavier
ceci pour éviter en ce qui concerne nos
radios télés type la machine bruyante
que l'on connaît le télé type classique
que tout le monde connaît qui est très
bruyant et en morse pas ma foi c'est
quand même un petit peu plus un peu
moins fatigantes et plus amusant de le
faire au clavier à l'écran
si vous comprenez cette conversation ne
prenez pas la route
en 1982 la vitesse d'un processeur d'un
ordinateur individuel c'est à peu près 1
méga on est très loin des gigas et des
multiprocesseurs rien que ton petit
smartphone contient plusieurs
processeurs de quelques gigas en gros tu
avais un coeur un processeur de 1 méga
ya les chaos et les méga octet yalinga
alors le truc comme la clé usb bat
oublie même pas en rêve
il n'y a pas encore de souris le lecteur
de disquettes t'oublie windows connais
pas le disque dur t'oublies pour stocker
les données battues utiliser un lecteur
de cassettes de poker se trouve sur une
bande d'une mini casse est tout à fait
normale et je vais demander aux systèmes
de charge et cette morne j'appuie sur la
touche lecture et pour charger un
logiciel ça pouvait prendre jusqu'à dix
minutes tout ça juste pour un jeu de
cartes
aweys en électronique des années 80 et
made in france quand même hein c'est
beau ça le programme est en train de
battre les cartes
je vais parier une somme qui sera par
exemple de 1000 milles du dollar voilà
les sommes que je vais gagner 6
j'ai quelque chose d'intéressant le
système m'a sorti automatiquement des
cartes il a vu lui même qui avait une
paire en conséquence il me signale que
je suis déjà en train de gagner une
paire
c'est à dire je vais en train de gagner
1000 dollars je peux demander les cartes
je vais demander par exemple
remplacement de la carte numéro 4 donc
je tape 4 je vais changer aussi le
valais qu'est la carte 5 ans d'accord
pour les changes et jeudi à l'isie à ce
moment là le système change ses cartes
les remplace par d'autres tirées au
hasard bien entendu il constate que je
n'ai qu'une paire donc j'ai gagné 1000
dollars voilà donc un exemple d'un jeu
ici le jeu de poker qui a été programmé
sur un petit ordinateur vous voyez que
la qualité de l'image est tout à fait
excellentes et que le jeu est très
simple à apprendre
nous sommes typiquement dans ce qu'on
appelle l'informatique individuelle
qualité d'image 1982 c'est aussi une
année qui voit apparaître le to7 de chez
thomson une entreprise française lui
c'était aux 7 70 c'est celui d'après en
fait il n'avait pas le même clavier
processeur motorola 68 09 à un méga
hertz ram 8 ko extensible à 32 k o
quand tu vois qu'aujourd'hui c'est
minimum 4 gigas de mémoire pour que ton
ordinateur fonctionne pas peu près bien
on l'appeler théo pour téléviseurs
ordinateurs
7 je sais pas 70 je sais pas non plus
ont branché directement l'ordinateur sur
sa télé avec une prise péritel fêtait de
la grosse bombe
c'est un ordinateur pour le grand public
pour la famille pour vous pour moi alors
que peut-on faire avec on peut faire
beaucoup de choses
on peut d'abord introduit l'ordinateur à
la maison pour se mettre dans le coup de
l'informatique et pour cela dans
l'ordinateur on peut immédiatement
introduire des langages comme le langage
basic ou langages logo on peut aussi
apprendre d'autres choses par exemple
les langues étrangères
il ya des programmes d'anglais des
programmes d'allemands qui se met très
simplement dans l'ordinateur
on peut aussi jouer avec l'ordinateur
des jeux d'intelligence ou des jeux
d'astuces là toute une série de jeux qui
sont prévus pour l'ordinateur
thomson était une marque très innovante
pour l'époque avec l'ordinateur il y
avait un stylo optique qui permettait
entre autres de faire des dessins
directement sur l'écran de votre
ordinateur
j'ai jamais compris comment ça
fonctionnait en ce début des années 80
on voit apparaître deux
nombreuses marques amstrad atari st
clair texas instruments amiga commodore
le problème c'est que c'est un peu le
bazar rien livré en standard et en plus
il faut connaître la programmation il
faut connaître le basic ou le pascal
c'est pas trés plug and play
malheureusement durant une décennie ce
marché ultra concurrentiel et aux
innovations constantes aura vu
apparaître et disparaître de nombreuses
marques et même thompson ya laissé des
plumes
la question n'est même plus de savoir si
un jour ou l'autre chacun d'entre nous
va l'acheter cet ordinateur individuel
c'est certain le grand problème est qu
allons-nous enfer là je crois qu'il faut
faire confiance notamment aux enfants
élevés avec dans un coin de la maison
cette machine devenue familière après
tout ce n'est pas parce que les gens
voulaient lire que gutenberg a inventé
l'imprimerie mais c'est parce que
gutenberg a inventé l'imprimerie que les
livres sont apparus que les gens se sont
mis à lire et que la civilisation est
entré dans une ère nouvelle
p3 l'industrie
du disque veut ta peau parce qu'avec le
mp3 le prix d'un disque peu baissé de
80%
c'est très simple il suffit d'avoir un
ordinateur connecté à internet
vous allez sur un site vous sélectionner
un fichier que vous télécharger sur
votre disque dur
gratuitement le tout sans payer le
moindre droit d'auteur 1993 apparaît le
mp3 parallèlement internet tisse sa
toile et quelques années plus tard le
monde est connecté 1999 apparaît un
programme conçu par trois développeurs
napster désormais le téléchargement
illégal est accessible à tous plus rien
ne sera comme avant
avant 1999 quand tu voulais de la
musique ben tu l'as acheté ou tu trouvé
un copain qui avait le cd original et
ucopia sur un cd vierge à l'aide d'un
graveur bref tu pirate ou alors tu aller
à la fnac
tu as acheté le cd tu le grave est chez
toi et tu retourner au magasin pour te
faire rembourser
ouais tu pouvais faire ça à cette époque
si le cd ne te plaisais pas tu pouvais
te le faire rembourser ou éventuellement
les changer ça n'a pas duré très
longtemps
après ils ont arrêté je ne sais pas trop
pourquoi non non je n'ai jamais fait non
oh non on me l'a raconté ses tons jaune
est moi bref 1999 c'est le début de la
démocratisation du piratage est ce qu'on
peut dire sa démocratisation du piratage
mais il existe une autre forme de
piratage dont vincent est un digne
représentant
il prend ses idées dans les magasins
traditionnels mais jamais plus il ne
leur achètera un disque j'ai connu les
fnac ou sur plusieurs étages il y avait
des kilomètres de rayon disques
je vous parle d'un temps que les moins
connaître très bien je pense que je vais
aller me vallet télécharger larmes de
vincent le mp3 de lettres et un chiffre
qui font trembler l'industrie du disque
mp3 c'est un nouveau format de
compression
il permet de faire passer de la musique
par internet du coup les internautes
s'organisent s'échangent des musiques et
pour se rencontrer il dispose même d'un
supermarché virtuel nom de code napster
c'est une bourse d'échangé international
de musique par exemple à l'heure
actuelle il ya une pub 1300 personnes
qui sont connectés et qui propose un
total de 106 1000 chansons disponibles
en téléchargement gratuit gratuitement
bien sûr j'ai plus d'une centaine de
réponses sur céline dion ça va du
premier album au dernier album qu'on
trouve à l'heure actuelle en magasin
donc là je vais lancer le téléchargement
de cette chambre sont là it's all coming
back
ce mec est en train de contourner la loi
pour du céline you et quelques minutes
plus tard
dans le même temps vincent a fait
tourner son graveur résultats donc
maintenant qu'il est gravé et je le sors
de donc sage est gravé un type de sujet
aurait pu graver tout l'album de céline
dion il aura fallu je télécharge les
autres chansons donc là en l'occurrence
jean les charges et qu'une ensuite je
vais tester sur ma chaine hifi up sur le
disque playes et est ce que ça marche ça
devrait marcher
voilà voilà pourquoi vinça on achète
plus de disque en magasin
coût de l'opération 10 francs le prix du
cd vierge bon il y avait deux écoles de
pirates ceux qui allaient l'adsl ou le
câble des vitesses de téléchargement
assez rapide pour l'époque quatre
minutes pour environ 4 mégas il y avait
les autres ceux qui utilisaient le 56
cas ce n'était pas très rapide comme son
nom l'indiqué le débit descendant était
de 56 kg bits par seconde maximum départ
rapide
c'était super pas rapide il fallait
entre 15 et 20 minutes de téléchargement
juste pour un titre un titre
tes longs et si la connexion échoué
pendant le téléchargement ce qui arrivé
très souvent
ben fallait tout recommencer le pirate à
l'époque ça se mérite est surtout que
les forfaits internet en 1999 avec 1 56
cas n'était pas illimitée cinquante
heures d'internet par mois et qu'ils
étaient contents c'est pour ça que
céline dion ça n'aurait pas été mon
premier choix
est ce que vous savez ce que vous
risquez en faisant ça pas vraiment pas
du tout même voix les deux ans de prison
et un million de francs d'amendé quand
même mais encore faut-il attraper les
gens qui téléchargent et qui graver des
cd
est-ce que vous avez le sentiment de
commettre d'une certaine manière un vol
en faisant ça je persiste à dire que je
trouve que le prix d'un cd est beaucoup
trop chère par rapport à la part que
prend l'artiste il a part que prend la
maison de disques s'il y avait un juste
milieu que l'artiste gagner autant que
la maison de disque là
il faudrait encore y réfléchir mais je
pense que ça changerait pas mal de
choses et le prix du cd ne serait pas de
moitié mais pas loin malgré la sanction
possible vous allez continuer ah oui ça
c'est sûr et certain
sans problème restant une sorte de robin
des bois de la musique je vole pour
redistribuer à moi même c'est vrai faut
bien l'avouer qu'à cette époque il y
avait un petit côté nagy on découvrait
internet et ce nouveau monde connecté
tout était à portée de main sans bouger
de la maison on pouvait télécharger
toutes les musiques que l'on voulait en
gros c'est comme si on offrait la fnac
on savait un petit peu que c'était
illégal mais la plupart du temps nous
voiler la face
c'était tellement facile et puis c'était
la maison qu'ils pouvaient savoir qu'ils
télécharger quoi qui faisait quoi voilà
le succès de napster et du piratage
était telle que dans certaines
universités le réseau était saturé
tellement ça télécharger toute
l'industrie du disque tremble devant ces
jeunes sociétés rebelles qui envahissent
internet des ventes de cd baissent déjà
et il est prévu qu'en 2005 10 % de la
musique soient vendus sur le net
et ça ce n'est pas une bonne nouvelle
pour tout le monde en ce qui est de 2
nous on compte sur vous pour nous
trouver
il a pris de la drogue alain et ouais à
partir des années 2000 ça a été le début
de la fin des grandes maisons de disques
qui arrivait à limiter la casse côté
piratage elle n'avait pas vu débarquer
le mp3 via internet
c'est ballot des millions de manque à
gagner un véritable pillage
aujourd'hui c'est 13 millions de pirates
à rien qu'en france 2,5 milliards de
contenus consommés illégalement deux ans
à peine après le lancement de napster en
juillet 2001 le logiciel est retiré
la justice américaine l'interdît pour
infraction à la législation sur le droit
d'auteur mais le mal est fait la boîte
est ouvert et on voit l'apparition de
nombreux programmes comme nous tels la
muse limewire pendant sa courte vie le
napster inégale a compté jusqu'à 50
millions d'utilisateurs dans le monde
ouais parce que maintenant fait napster
il est devenu légal je crois qu'ils ont
gardé le nom surtout dans les années
2000 les connexions internet sont de
plus en plus rapide après le mp3 pour la
musique on voit apparaître de nouveaux
formats le mp4
cette fois ci pour la vidéo
et déjà les premiers films sont
disponibles sur internet
ces nouvelles technologies soulève de
nombreuses questions
faudra-t-il demain redéfinir la notion
de droits d'auteur la création est elle
vraiment en danger ou saura-t-elle
s'adapter comme elle l'a toujours fait
[Musique]